Christoph,
let me ask you,
why do you think that the Truman has
never come close to discovering the true
nature of his world?
Until now,
we accept the reality of the world with
which group presented.
It's as simple as that.
In the beginning of the Truman show,
a star falls from the sky.
Well,
a light falls from the ceiling of a sky
high set that encloses an artificial
town built for the life of one man and
the entertainment of the whole world.
The light says serious nine Kennis
major,
which refers to serious the brightest
star in the night sky.
This star,
which homer one's called an evil
portent,
bringing heat and fevers to suffering
humanity in the film.
The falling of Sirius is the first in a
series of ruptures in Truman's fake
reality.
A series that ends here with an actual
rupture of breaching things as they are
like in homework,
Peter,
we are director of the Truman show
envisions this door into real reality in
darker terms than you might expect.
All the symbols we usually associate
with goodness and positivity are behind
Truman.
Bright blue skies,
Sun beams breaking through the clouds
and expansive sea of possibility,
reality,
truth and authenticity on the other hand
are relegated to a small single
rectangle of shadow,
hardly the light at the end of the
tunnel that we normally associate with
liberation.
All throughout the film.
Freedom for Truman is linked tightly
with trauma.
Every peak behind the curtain is
accompanied by some form of pain,
whether it's the pain of seeing the
image of a deceased loved one,
the pain of a true connection abruptly
cut short,
the pain of memory,
or simply the pain of uncertainty of not
knowing what it is you're seeing.
That's of course the pain that we're all
familiar with.
It's why for the most part,
we see only what we want to see.
Truman has been privy to a lifetime full
of hints,
clues to the fact that his world is not
as it seems.
Yes,
which we incorporate those clues
to reconfigure the entire narrative of
his existence and rewrites like that
just aren't free.
They cost,
they cost suffering.
Peter,
we're in writer Andrew.
Nicole were prophetic about so much from
the vantage of 1998,
the ubiquity of reality television,
the rise of mass surveillance.
They keyed in perfectly to my parents'
generation of cold war,
paranoia of being watched or bugged and
my own generation of narcissism where it
bugs us not to be watched,
and that's a great joy of the Truman
show,
the allegories and layered readings.
The headiness of it all stands out
vividly even for a kid like I was when I
saw it at age 10.
It's not pedantic or preachy.
It just asked so many damn questions
that they're impossible to ignore the
hell you talking about who you talking
to and actually I was watching it again
recently and I was really struck by how
easily the Truman show can be read as an
allegory for the present.
Like Truman's town of sea haven.
Our own world seems to be experiencing a
similar series of ruptures.
Rupture is like the great recession in
2008,
the Arab spring,
like the killings of young black men by
police or are increasing awareness of
them like Brexit,
the splitting of the UK from Europe and
most recently like the rise of the
political outsider movements of Bernie
Sanders and Donald Trump.
I think American society at large is a
lot like truman,
burbank laboring like him for 30 plus
years under a system that is finally
showing itself to be ridiculous.
Society like Truman is trying to wake
itself up while stumbling under the pain
that surfaces from doing so.
The Truman show is a massive operation
with a crew and cast of thousands,
but for all the power that Christophe
commands,
the show's success always hinges on
Truman himself and can only work if
truman believes in it.
He couldn't leave at anytime.
If you are absolutely determined to
discover the truth,
there's no way we could prevent the
powerful in our world.
Hold things in place like Christophe
holds true,
but we hold ourselves in place to,
if nothing else,
it's clear that in 2016 we are slowly
waking up into a new political reality
like in Truman's world,
the power relationships of our own have
gained in consolidated strength by
convincing us that they're normal like
laws of nature,
by taking any breach and folding it back
into the narrative.
They've kept all those like Truman who
are perennial losers at bay,
but ideologies don't last forever.
Eventually they crumble under their own
weight and the increasing refusal of
people to believe in.
Thank you for your help.
You're welcome chairman.
The Truman show shows us what waking up
looks like.
It stages in a really valuable way.
The struggles that come with it.
It shows how the messaging of the
dominant ideology is absorbed into media
and into education.
It shows us how individual people,
even people we trust,
good people can become the mouthpieces
of a rotten system.
Everybody is in on it.
I'd have to be in a two and most
importantly evolve.
The Truman show imagines liberation not
as utopia,
but as a world flawed,
like our own full of multiplicity and
contradiction and people obsessed with
TV.
It's a world gained only by struggle and
paint,
one that often looks like an evil
portend in the moment.
It's not a sunburst and the clouds or an
endless seat,
but a small shadowy door that leads off
to a territory unmapped but invested
hopefully with a greater authenticity in
case I don't say.
Yeah,
good afternoon.
Good evening.
There is a new nerve writer video every
Wednesday,
so if you go right there and click on
that,
you'll subscribe to this channel,
get all the videos.
And that's what helps me out the most.
The Truman show blows my mind every time
I watch it.
I saw it in the theaters when I was 10
in 1998 with my mom,
and it was one of the best movie
experiences,
the formative movie experiences of my
life.
Um,
so this was a blast to make.
Thanks so much for watching.
Again.
I'll see you guys next Wednesday.